what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to another season seven predictions
video for those of you that are fans of
the golden company make sure you go over
to calais channel that way you can watch
our most recent collaboration we did
together in that video we discussed the
future of the night King and what he
will be up to next season I will put the
links for that video down in my
description but in this one I'm going to
list all the characters I think will die
plus the characters the plot League said
will die during season seven
I have several written down here so this
may take more than one video to do so
with that being said let's get right
into this make sure all of you comment
below with your season 7 predictions to
which characters do you think will die
but let's start this video off with a
major character that's going to die next
season which will be Littlefinger the
plot league said Littlefinger will die
next season and I absolutely agree with
that I'm still not sure he will die the
exact same way the plot league said but
I do think he will die next season most
of the politics will be getting wrapped
up to make way for the war against the
night King and I think Littlefinger will
be one of those characters to go the
north will need the Vale or me on their
side and with Littlefinger in the way it
definitely complicates things because he
obviously cannot be trusted at all the
plot league said songs that will
sentence him to death which Arya will
then carry out I think that would be a
cool way for him to die by the hands of
one of the Starks but I actually think
he could die another way which is
through the moon door
if you want to find out more about that
check out my sons a stark takeover video
Littlefinger is a great addition to the
show and although he does deserve to die
his scheming manipulating and treachery
will be missed by many and speaking of
the Vale army the next person on my list
is Yann Royce I think there is going to
be a little bit of a power struggle with
the Vale army next season Littlefinger
does have a lot of influence over sweet
Robyn which basically gives Littlefinger
control of the Vale army but I think
songs that will start to use her
influence over sweet Robyn to keep the
Vale forces fighting with the north no
matter what type of backdoor deals
Littlefinger may be up to but I think
somehow Yan Royce will get in
Littlefinger's way and I think
Littlefinger is going to have him killed
Littlefinger may fear that Royce
sweet Robbins ear turning him against
him and I think this is when Yan Royce
will bite the dust
we already saw back in season sighs how
easily this man could have been killed
just on the word of Littlefinger sweet
Robin was going to have him killed then
but Littlefinger changed his mind I
think one little finger realizes Sansa
is a dead end he may aim his sights
elsewhere and this is when Yan Royce may
try and step in or overplay his hand and
then that's when Littlefinger will make
sure this man is out of his way
now this next one's not an easy one for
me to say because although this
character hasn't been featured that much
I still really like him but I think him
and his crew are all definitely going to
die next season this character is
dolorous EDD in the Nights Watch the
Nights Watch is probably my favorite
part of the story to be honest with you
Jon Snow was the first character I
really connected with when I first
started watching the show and by default
I grew really fond of the Nights Watch
and their storyline I could honestly
watch a show based solely on the Nights
Watch
that's how interesting and intriguing
the wall and everything going on at the
wall and beyond the wall is to me but I
think most of us knew this day would
come the white Walker threat is
increasing by each episode and it's just
a matter of time before they breach the
wall and when they do the Nights Watch
will be completely decimated if you've
seen any of my other videos then you
know that I think the entire Nights
Watch at Castle black will be killed by
the night king and then raised as whites
to fight in his army and I wouldn't be
surprised if Lord Commander Eadie's
killed and turned into a white and then
John is eventually the one that has to
put him down I think that would be a
heartbreaking scene for John to have to
do this to one of his best friends one
of his brothers but it would also be the
heart-wrenching type of scene that Game
of Thrones tends to do to us and since
we're talking about characters that
we'll end up fighting for the night King
this leads me to the next character that
I think will die during season seven
this was in the plot lead - so I can't
take full credit for this one but this
one is Benjen stark Benjen stark is
currently beyond the wall all alone
surrounded by the night king's army so
it's just a matter of time before they
catch up to him if they haven't already
and according to benjin they did try to
kill him once but he said the children
of the forest were able to save him by
plunging dragonglass into his heart
like they did with the night game benjin
says he's still fighting for the living
but we do not know this for a fact he
could possibly be sending brand through
the wall on purpose to allow the night
King through but who really knows but
according to the plot leaked Uncle
Benjen will be getting swarmed by an
army of whites while he is rescuing John
north of the wall
once again I'm not quite sure it's going
to go down like this but I absolutely
think benjin will end up fighting for
the night king in his army and I also
think John will end up having to be the
one to kill his uncle Benjen it will be
sad as [ __ ] but I think there is going
to go down like that John will be left
with no choice but to permanently kill
Benjen stark the next person on my list
is Euron Greyjoy which I just made a
video about recently as well I
definitely think you're on is there died
next season a king has died during every
single season and out of the remaining
kings on the show Euron is definitely
going to be the first one to go I think
your on will do some significant damage
to Dany sleet early next season and he
will also capture some of Danny's allies
and then he will align himself with
Cersei Euron will definitely cause some
damage next season but by the end of the
season he is definitely going to die
it's unfortunate because Euron could be
a game changer if you've read the
forsaken chapter than you know shits
about to go down and your honors just
getting warmed up but in the television
show he has been brought in too late and
he's underdeveloped as unlikely as this
may sound I think beyond could end up
being the one to kill your own next
season
I think Theon could come face-to-face
with Joran and attempt to save his
sister Yara and what you're on is going
to underestimate him
or I also think Jaime Lannister could
end up killing your own Jaime is not
going to be a fan of this guy nor is he
going to like the alliance that he makes
with his sister
I feel like Jaime is going to have some
problems with urine which could lead to
his death I think you're on leaves the
show just as fast as he was brought in
and it will probably be a season 7
finale death septa unella will also die
during season 7 sir she had her strapped
down to a table and left for the
mountain to play with Cersei said she
was not going to kill her right away but
she was going to brutally torture her
instead she will definitely not be
treated well by the mountain but at some
point next season I do think we're going
to get a glimpse into that
again where she was strapped down and
when we see that room again where the
mountain was left with her I think we're
just going to see a disgusting mess left
behind
Cersei said she was not meant to die
today she will not die for a while and
unfortunately for septa unella this is
going to be true but she will eventually
be killed most likely by bleeding to
death after the mountain is finished
with her and speaking of torture this
leads me to the next set of characters
that are going to die which are the sand
snakes and al aureus and according to
the plot leaked two of the sand snakes
will die during an attack out at sea
with Joran Greyjoy apparently you're on
catches up to a portion of Danny's fleet
most likely the motel and Greyjoy fleet
in what urine waits them out killing two
of the sand snakes in the process and
capturing the rest including you're a
Greyjoy
after this takes place it appears that
you're on takes these prisoners to
King's Landing most likely as an
offering to Cersei Lannister when the
sand snakes end up in Cersei's hands
their fate is sealed Cersei knows they
killed her daughter Marcella so there is
no way the sand snakes or ilaria will
ever leave King's Landing alive again I
definitely think she will stick the
mountain on them just like she did what
septa unella
we know if there was anything in this
world that Circe truly loved it was her
children and considering ilaria killed
one of those children's services only
daughter she will not show them any kind
of mercy I wouldn't be surprised to see
them killed in the same exact episode
that they arrived to be honest with you
but moving on the next character that
dies next season in my opinion will be
grey worm I think at some point next
season Daenerys and John will lose a big
character out of their group the series
is getting very close to its end and we
know it's going to have a bittersweet
ending with many many deaths leading up
to it and I think next season we're
going to feel some big losses out of
these two camps Daenerys is going to
lose someone close to her which may even
further motivate her to join forces with
John and I think that person on her team
that dies is going to be grey worm we
know from the reports that grey worm
will be involved in most likely the
biggest battle next season so he might
die in that battle there was also an
interesting piece of evidence from the
newly released photos by HBO if you look
at this group photo of Danny Tyrion
missandei Varys and grey worm you can
see that grey worm is wearing a pin on
chest a silver circular pen and
missandei is not wearing that pen but in
the other photo released by HBO we can
see that missandei is now wearing this
same pen grey worm was wearing
we know that missandei and grey worm are
very close and are attracted to each
other so it is possible that grey worm
gave it to her as a gift but I think it
could also mean that grey worm a dye
which then missandei wears this pen a
sort of a remembrance for grey worm
someone she did care for and like and
I'll do one more death prediction for
this video that way it's not too long of
a video for you guys but I will make a
part 2 video because there are still
several more characters that I believe
will die next season but the last
character for this video will be sweet
Robin I absolutely think sweet Robin
will die next season and his eyes might
go right off that moon door to make the
bad boy fly like I said earlier in this
video I do think that there will be a
power struggle with the Vale next season
and sweet Robin is already a underused
character who will not likely come into
play in the end I think songs are will
end up with control of the Vale army but
not before a little finger most likely
tries to fully secure the Vale for
himself
I think Littlefinger could also have
sweet wealth and killed Littlefinger is
really going to start to feel himself
losing his grip and losing his power
next season he's going to become more
desperate when he realizes he can't run
to Cersei and he can no longer
manipulate Shawn's oh and all he's going
to have left is sweet Robin but I think
songs they may be able to turn sweet
Robin against Littlefinger I think if
anybody can do that it would be Songza
and I doubt Littlefinger will want to
lose control of the Vale and if he feels
like Songza and Robin are closing him
out that's when he's going to act and
he's going to have sweet Robin and Yan
Royce killed which would pretty much
leave nobody in his way in the Eyrie
giving him full control of the Vale Game
of Thrones is going to start thinning
the herd very soon we're going to lose
most of these characters by the end and
considering the war against the 19 is
coming during season 8 they're going to
need to kill off all these little side
plots that are going on to make way for
John and Danny to be mainly featured for
this battle in the end and ultimately a
bittersweet ending if you're not on John
or Danny's team by season 8 I think your
character is expendable for sure but in
the final battle it doesn't matter whose
team
you're on most of them are going to die
anyway but anyways these are just some
of my predictions for next season I
could be wrong with some of these but
deep down I do feel like these are some
of the characters that need to be pushed
out of the way so that they can focus on
what's important and who is important
and quite frankly none of these
characters listed are important in terms
of the grand scheme of things so they
must go comment below with your season 7
death predictions let me know which
characters you think are going to die
next season I'm curious to see what you
think especially if you have any big
characters you think are going to die
and definitely want to know who and why
as always thanks for stopping by and
watching this video thanks for
commenting down below I always like
discussing these things with you all
also a special thanks to the patreon
supporters Bosko Laurie daughter of Ice
and Fire
Christopher Thomas Travis Darren the
drunken bran the Builder
Sir Thomas cipher Schuyler Kari marine
Kyle Bryn Martin Jeanette golden girl
neck gene James the indie sports car
podcast and my main girl Brit aka Theon
defense squad thank you all so much and
I'll see you down below bye